Mike Myers once threatened to quit his
own movie rather than Give In Studio
demands and it resulted in his most
iconic scene ever Amber herd has gone
nude on film before but when it came
Time to Go Topless for 2018s London
Fields she flat out refused and
consequently was sued by The Producers
based on Martin amos' 1989 novel of the
same name the film stars heard is Nicola
6 a clairvoyant fem fatal who predicts
she will be killed by one of her three
lovers given that both the script and
novel it was based on were according to
the lawsuit so ious provocative and
contained nude scenes producers argued
that herd was well aware she'd be asked
to take her clothes off producers also
argued that herd didn't just disrupt the
production but also damaged the film's
publicity they alleged that herd was
contractually obligated to attend the
premiere at the Toronto International
Film Festival which she didn't and that
she even tried to get the film pulled
from Tiff's lineup which it was the
production company Nicholas 6 limited
sued herd for $10 million but later
settled out of court Jim ciso became a
household name for his role as Jesus
Christ in m ion's 2003 passion project
The Passion of the Christ before going
biblical though he was already well on
his way to being the next big
Blockbuster heartthrob with parts in
films like Angel Eyes where theout
Catholic raised eyebrows when he
wouldn't do a love scene with Jennifer
Lopez unless she kept her clothes on he
likewise refused to film a love scene
with his Monte Christo co-star Daga
Dominic unless she put something between
her breasts and his chest she wound up
taking flesh colored underwear and
fashioning pasties from it gisel told
the independent that his commitment to
staying clothed is out of respect for
his wife and his Catholic faith if it's
embarrassing for people on set if they
think you're a wimp that you're an
embarrassment talking this way well I'd
rather be embarrassed before the whole
country than before God for a decade
Robert Downey Jr was the Lynch pin of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe which gave
him a lot of power behind the scenes to
shape the films he appeared in one of
the times that the actor used this sway
was at the end of the 2012 film The
Avengers having helped stop Loki and
prevent the destruction of New York Iron
Man is left tumbling through the sky
before crashing into the Hulk he
awakened surrounded by his fellow Heroes
and was initially supposed to say what's
next but Downey Jr was apparently
unhappy with this line and didn't want
to film it instead he worked with
director Jos Weeden to come up with an
alternative the result was one of the
most iconic moments in the MCU you ever
tried schwarma there's a schwarma joint
about two blocks from here I don't know
what it is but I want to try it released
in 2018 the action adventure film
Rampage features Dwayne Johnson as a
former Special Forces soldier who
befriends an albino ape known as George
as a result of a genetic experiment
George can grow to enormous sizes and is
pursued by the US Military and me of a
gene manipulation company the unlikely
friends ultimately end up having to save
Chicago and other animals exposed to the
same pathogen wreak havoc in the city
Johnson only had one problem when he
first read the script for Rampage and
that was the fact that George died at
the end while the filmmakers tried to
Plate the actor by arguing that he dies
as a hero sacrificing himself Johnson
was dumbfounded that his ape friend had
to die he outlined his reasoning to
Rolling Stone arguing that people want
to come to his movies to see a happy
ending I don't like a sad ending life
brings that I don't want it in my movies
when the credits roll I want to feel
feel great the disagreement between the
actor his producers and Studio
Executives lasted some 2 months before
they managed to come to a compromise
solution that satisfied everyone
producer Bo Flynn confirmed that Johnson
simply refused to back down and was
adamant that George should not die 1994
was a huge year for comedian and actor
Jim krey he rocketed to fame thanks to
his appearances in three hit films Ace
Ventura Pet Detective the mask and of
course Dumb and Dumber directed by Peter
Farley the movie sees Carrie portray
Lloyd Christmas alongside Jeff Daniels
who plays his best friend Harry Dunn the
two Slackers and idiots end up traveling
across the country as they try to return
a briefcase to Mary Swanson
inadvertently becoming involved in a
kidnapping plot along the way Dumb and
Dumber ends with a pair beginning the
long journey back home to Rhode Island
while walking down a road a bus filled
with bikini clad women invites them to
be oil boys for the group as they tour
the US the pair decline with Lloyd
instead pointing them in the direction
of the town they just left however this
was not how the scene was originally
intended to play out with the script
initially having the two friends get on
the boss partly EXP explained to The
Hollywood Reporter how the studio felt
this was necessary as it provided a
happy ending the audience would enjoy
Carrie and Farley disagreed committed to
the fact that his character was so dumb
that he wouldn't seize this opportunity
Carrie refused to film that version of
the scene with Farley reporting that the
actor said I'm not stepping foot on that
bus I won't do it you'll have to excuse
my friend he's a little
slow the town is back that
way in 2015's super scary suspense film
sakario Emily blunt plays an FBI agent
battling drug cartels along the Mexican
border a scene called for blunt To Go
Topless while the scene was written in
the script blunt later told interviewer
Howard Stern that when it came time to
film she refused blunt was backed up by
co-star bonio Del Toro who agreed that
the scene wasn't necessary given that
Del Toro played the film's titular
Hitman nobody wanted to mess with him or
with blunt the scene was cut into the
blue is a 2005 action film that sees
Paul Walker and Jessica Alba portray a
couple who become embroiled in a massive
criminal drug op operation when a plane
crashes in the sea near their home it
ended up being a commercial and critical
failure one of the perils facing the
characters is the risk of sharks this
proved to be a point of contention for
Alba who wasn't prepared to swim with
any of the animals during filming the
actor explained that the filmmakers
wanted her to swim near a live tiger
shark that was behind a cage to provide
some extra realism fearing for her own
safety Alba fought against the idea and
ultimately refused to film the scene
with any real life sharks swimming in
the same water as her instead choosing
to return to shore Chris Columbus's 199
3 comedy Mrs downfire easily ranks among
Robin williams' best ever films the
movie follows Williams as Daniel Hillard
who goes to a complicated divorce with
his wife Miranda and finds himself
unable to see his children as often as
he would like to combat this Daniel
takes on the Persona of an elderly woman
known as Mrs dfire who acts as a
housekeeper and Nanny giving the father
more time to see his kids as well as
being incredibly funny the film expertly
deals with issues around family
separation and abandonment by the end
Daniel and Miranda come to find a new
respect for each other and put in place
a plan for joint custody putting forward
the idea that the children should come
first but this message was almost eroded
in the original script as it concluded
with the separated couple getting back
together to make one big happy family
Williams and director Chris Columbus
pushed back believing that this ending
was neither realistic nor helpful to
younger viewers who might watch it and
therefore expect their own parents to
get backed together they eventually won
the argument with the filmmakers and
Studio Executives relenting if you've
ever seen any of Sasha Baron Cohen's
work you know the star has zero issues
with filming in his birthday suit or
with doing anything in poor taste for
that matter so it's no surprise that he
expects the same nonchalant about nudity
from his co-stars but one of his famous
female scene Partners Flatout refused to
go nude despite baratz badgering Rebel
Wilson is known for her body anything
goes brand of humor as rebal as Rebel is
she does draw the line when it comes to
dropping her drawers she refuses to go
nude and has it written into her
contracts that her Clos stay on in 2016
the brothers Grimsby Wilson played the
girlfriend of Cohen's screw up turn spy
character in one scene called for full
frontal nudity despite having a body
double Cohen wanted Wilson to be the one
to Bear all Wilson refused telling Metro
I'm like I'm not doing it I don't care
what you say Will Smith was riding high
in the early 1990s with a successful
hip-hop career as the fresh prince and
an even more successful TV show The
Fresh Prince of Belair but an important
transition from sitcoms to Serious film
roles was 1993's 6 degrees of separation
based on the play of the same name the
movie has a dense character-driven plots
and complicated themes and while Smith
was willing to take risks the script
called for something he refused to do in
the film Smith's character is required
to share a passionate kiss with his male
co-star Anthony Michael Hall Smith was
uncomfortable with this and sought
advice from Denzel Washington who
reportedly told him not to kiss a man on
camera so that's precisely what Smith
didn't do the shot was filmed from
behind allowing Smith to fake it by
keeping several Degrees of Separation
from his male co-star Smith started a
pattern of strategically avoiding
controversy until of course the 2022
incident in which Smith slapped Chris
Rock on stage at the Oscars
when it comes to being difficult Mike
Myers has earned Mythic status however
for all of his diva-like Demands a lot
of myers' stubbornness is actually for
the betterment of the movie Case in
point making Shrek Scottish in the
middle of production cost DreamWorks
millions of dollars but was the right
call I'm an ogre you know grab your
torch and
pitchforks but there's no better example
of Myers making artistic demands than
this story about the most famous scene
in Wayne's World if you think of Wayne's
World you probably think of Wayne G in
theame headbanging and lipsyncing to
Queen's Bohemian rap city according to
Myers though it almost wasn't Queen's
Masterpiece they sang to but a Guns and
Roses tune instead fortunately he stuck
to his guns and refused to film the
scene unless it was Bohemian rap city
even threatened to walk away from the
film despite it being his first movie
Myers got his way saving the now iconic
scene and establishing a reputation that
follows him to this day the Shaw Shank
Redemption is considered a classic even
though it was far from a box office
success when it first hit Cinema screens
in 1994 based on a 1982 Stephen King
Nolla the film stars Tim Robbins is a
wrongly incarcerated prisoner named Andy
dufrain Who develops a strong friendship
with Morgan Freeman's convict character
red the film further cemented Freeman's
reputation as a star but the actor also
demonstrated that he was unwilling to
compromise on quality the ending of the
Sha Shank Redemption sees Andy dufrain
finally escape from prison following a
decades long scheme red is later
released on parole and after struggling
to live an everyday life outside of his
cell decides to meet up with Andy in
Mexico in the final moments the two
friends see each other on a beach and
embrace as a camera pans away Freeman
later revealed that director and writer
Frank Darabont wanted a slightly
different ending speaking to the Daily
News Freeman explained that the script
initially had read blowing Andy's old
harmonica before they met on the beach
however the actor thought this was quote
sort of asinine sort of cliche sort of
unnecessary and Overkill and simply
refused Morgan was able to convince
Darren bond to have a more
straightforward and impactful reunion
instead although there has been a lot of
debate about which actor was the best
James Bond John conry consistently ranks
highly connory was the first actor to
play the character on the big screen and
set a precedent that all others would be
judged by with his effortless portrayal
of the British spy in total the actor
played 007 in six films produced by Eon
Productions plus The Unofficial Never
Say Never Again in 1983 during that time
Conor's character faced numerous
challenges and dangers but one proved
too much for the Scottish actor during
filming for Thunderball connory was
required to go into a pool filled with
sharks not particularly thrilled with
the idea of swimming with sharks connory
demanded changes to the scene before he
got in the water including the inst of a
plexiglass Shield to separate him from
the live animals but there wasn't enough
plexiglass which allowed the Sharks to
reach the actor who made a swift exit
and decided not to get back in the pool
the episode may have also led to his
nervousness at having to scuba di with
sharks for Never Say Never Again some
years later underwater stuff I'm not
very good at it and was very very
nervous about going under making his
first appearance in 1977's the spy who
loved me Richard Kel's Jaws is an
assassin and henchman who is well known
within the criminal underworld the
character was initially intended to be
killed during the final moments of the
movie but after test screenings The
Producers decided to keep Jaws alive due
to his popularity that led to Jaws
appearing in the next entry in the
series 1979's Moonraker this time around
he was more of a comedic foil than a
Relentless killer although he does pose
a serious threat to bond before he's
reformed eventually Jaws fights against
super villain Hugo draxx and works with
Bond largely as a result of his
relationship with new girlfriend dolly
in an original draft of the script jaw's
love interest would have been a hulking
woman even taller than the 7'2 in
character portrayed by Keel but Keel
didn't like this idea and threatened to
quit the production in the book some
kind of hero the remarkable story of the
James Bond films Heil explained I felt
strongly that what they had in mind
wouldn't work for me or the audience how
about a short girl I said how short I
said well at least five 5et like several
of the main cast of The Fast and Furious
franchise Michelle Rodriguez has been a
constant throughout a series that now
numbers in the double figures in terms
of theatrical releases the actor plays
Ley Ortiz a skilled Street racer and
mechanic who operates as part of Dominic
teto's crew in the very first movie it's
established that Ley and Dom are
involved in a romantic relationship
something that is continued in
subsequent films but that might not have
been the case if Rodriguez hadn't argued
against the storyline in the Fast and
the Furious that would have seen lety
cheating on Dom with Paul Walker's
character Brian o'conor unwilling to be
perceived as a cheater and believing
that these events would not have been
believable to audiences she fought
against the love triangle idea the actor
went to the filmmakers and demanded that
the scenes be removed from the script
before filming took Place threatening to
quit the project altogether if they
insisted on keeping them fortunately
diesel felt similarly and backed up his
co-star helping to convince those in
charge to drop the arc and keep the
relationship between Dom and Ley strong
the James Bond franchise seems to have a
penchant for including scenes that
actors find uncomfortable the most
recent example of this came about in
2015 Spectre which saw Rai fines
continue in the role of M following the
death of the previous incarnation of the
character portrayed by Judy Dench finds
revealed on the happy sad confused
podcast that director Sam Mendes
initially wanted the film to reveal that
M was in fact the criminal mastermind
known as blofeld findes recall telling
the director I don't want to play M and
then you turn around and make him the
bad guy mem is never the bad guy so
there's a set of boxes that are ticked
which the fan base expects and wants
this led to what the actor described as
pretty intense discussions with the
director before the pair agreed that M
wouldn't be revealed as the overarching
antagonist Denzel Washington is one of
the most celebrated actors of modern
times not only has he appeared in some
of the most uccessful films in recent
history winning numerous high-profile
Awards in the process but he's also a
producer and director with a lot of
power and influence in Hollywood so if
Washington doesn't want to do a scene
the chances are that no one is going to
be able to force him to do it that was
definitely the case for the 1993 legal
thriller the Pelican Brief where he
co-stars with Julia Roberts as the two
attempt to uncover the real motives
behind a series of assassinations at the
top of us Politics the two characters
develop a close relationship during the
course of the story leading to questions
about why they never kiss on screen or
seemingly develop a romance despite the
indications Roberts told Newsweek in
2002 that it was Washington's idea not
hers to have the scenes removed from the
script Washington explained that after
backlash from black audience members
over a kiss shown in a test screening of
1989's the Mighty Quinn he decided to
avoid such scenes in the future in order
to keep from alienating his biggest fan
Air Force One is a 1997 action thriller
that stars Harrison Ford as President
James Marshall who is aboard the
presidential aircraft when it is
hijacked by a terrorist group the movie
also features Glen close as vice
president Bennett who leads a response
to the hijacking on the ground from the
White House ensuring that the vice
president was a strong female leader who
would Inspire others around her and take
charge was evidently important to close
with the actor going so far as to refuse
to shoot a scene that compromised his
vision close revealed to Vanity Fair
that the script called for a scene where
the character would break down and cry
due to the overwhelming nature of the
situation close bulked at the idea and
spoke out to the filmmakers making it
clear that she wouldn't film such a
scene though she did allow a single tear
to fall she explained I said I will not
do that I don't think that would happen
not my vice president my vice president
would step up to the challenge I'm here
to assure the American people that we
are doing everything we can to resolve
the situation your highness is a 2011
Stoner comedy that stars Danny McBride
and James Franco as two medieval princes
determined to kill an evil sorcerer who
is holding a Prince's hostage and thus
save the Kingdom from his machinations
filled with the same kind of humor that
made films like Pineapple Express such
hits it's exactly the type of film you'd
never expect to see Natalie Portman in
but according to McBride Portman was
more than willing to embrace the filthy
jokes and join in on the fun he told
Cinema Blend on the set she never shot
away from that stuff I mean she can
definitely hang with the boys she wasn't
intimidated by any of the foul stuff
going on yet there was one thing that
Portman was unwilling to do at one point
in the movie Her character Isabelle
jumps into a lake Nearly Naked Portman
flat out refused to do that scene but
only because of how cold the water was
prompting a body double to step in for
Portman told the Daily Star there was
one shot that's me and the shot of her
diving into the water is a body double
because I didn't want to go on the water
it was really really
cold over the course of the last 30
years Ben Affleck has established
himself as one of the biggest Leading
Men in Hollywood and one of his most
celebrated performances came in David
Fincher's 2014 film Gone Girl starring
opposite Roseman Pike during one scene
Fincher wanted applex character Nick
Dunn to wear a New York Yankees baseball
cap as part of his attempts to travel
unnoticed through an airport but the
actor who comes from Massachusetts and
is well known as a huge fan of the
Boston Red Sox couldn't bring himself to
wear the hat of such a hated rival
Affleck recall to the New York Times how
he told Fincher he wouldn't film the
scene if he had to put on the cap saying
David I love you I would do anything for
you but I will not wear a Yankees hat I
just can't I can't wear it because it's
going to become a thing finer later
confirmed the story in the Gone Girl DVD
commentary saying perhaps jokingly that
the argument led to the Film halting
Production before they compromised on a
Mets hat I really wanted it to be a
Yankees cap but being from Boston and
not being very professional as an actor
Ben refused to wear a Yankees cap I mean
it did not come to blows but we had to
shut down production for 4 days Warner
Brothers has been playing catch-up with
Marvel Studios for some time now and has
never quite managed to capture the same
level of success 2017's Justice League
was the first Ensemble superhero film in
the DC extended universe and a chance
for the franchise to really kick into
gear but things didn't quite work out
that way and there were numerous issues
with the film many arising from the fact
that director Zack Snyder was replaced
by Jos Weeden during post-production for
extensive re-shoot one of the scenes
that weaton decided to include in his
version of the movie was a moment when
the flash played by Ezra Miller Falls on
G gut's Wonder Woman what was intended
to be a comedy moment ended up being
slightly creepy something that gdut was
quite aware of at the time according to
online rumors gdut refused to film the
scene as she felt it was sexualizing her
character unnecessarily and didn't fit
in with the rest of the movie's content
and theme instead the scene was
supposedly filmed using a stunt double
something unfortunately not true of the
film's other ippy
scenes you're gorgeous and Fierce and
strong and Pian Reeves has had one of
the most varied careers in Hollywood
long before John wicker The Matrix
though he was cast in the horror film
Bram Stoker's Dracula alongside Gary
Oldman Anthony Hopkins and Winona Ryder
released in 1992 it was directed by
Francis Ford Copa with Reeves taken on
the role of solicitor Jonathan Harker
and riter his fiance Mina Murray at one
point during filming the legendary
director took an unusual and unwelcome
approach to try and get Ryder to cry
convincingly on screen from behind the
camera he began to shout explo lives at
the actor calling her a [__] repeatedly
when he tried to have the rest of the
cast do the same in an attempt to force
Ryder to cry Reeves and Hopkins both
refused to take part this sparked a
close friendship between Ryder and
Reeves that has lasted for several
decades writer told the Sunday Times
literally Richard E Grant Anthony
Hopkins Keanu Francis was trying to get
all of them to yell things that would
make me cry but keano wouldn't Anthony
wouldn't it just didn't work I was like
really I kind of did the
opposite